Modern Warfare's warzone has some
surprising twists on the Battle Royale
formula and this quick guide we've got a
few essential tips that you need to know
to help you survive and even emerge
victorious from the warzone down but not
out aka don't give up buddy as obvious
as this tip may seem warzone takes a
slightly different approach to the loop
of running gunning and quitting to join
another game when you get picked off by
a player hiding behind a tree or a door
like an absolute coward
every Battle Royale game is about
staying alive as long as you can
obviously but avoiding death in warzone
might be more critical than in most
other about Royales between the Gulag
system and the ample buy station
scattered around the map there are lot
of chances for your squad to get back
into full fighting strength and even
make a big comeback in most other squad
focused battle royale games losing a
teammate might result in fear and
aimlessness but in warzone you've got a
decent shot at reviving them provided
you have the cash and can make it to the
right spot so stay focused and stay calm
even when the odds are against you you
might be down or you're not always out
use that ping baby if you played apex
legends or fortnight you'll know how is
sensual that ping system is it allows
you to easily mark a spot in your field
of vision highlight a weapon and of
course enemies in the distance
can't a warzone has a robust ping system
that also helps you easily communicate
with your teammates even if you're not
using voice chat to talk with them the
ping system contextually marked items
you focus on and double tapping it
allows you to indicate active hot zones
and locations where some actions are
bout to go down even if you're talking
with your teammates or playing with
friends get used to using the ping
system extensively it helps with
maintaining situational awareness under
here
yeah just apply remember mount your
weapons as mentioned in the tutorial
one thing you should get used to and
even make a habit of is mounting your
guns this involves using an object
nearby to steady your weapon which in
turn reduces the amount of recoil you
have to compensate for when firing
understandably this can be easy to
figure in the middle of combat while
there are certainly times were it's
better to maintain your mobility the
ability to fire accurately can mean the
difference between life and death
win or loss try to make use of this
early and as often as you can when
playing war zone so that you can build a
muscle memory rather than allowing the
ability to become an afterthought always
pick up bounty and scavenge contracts
contracts are a side objective you and
your squad can pick up in the field to
earn some extra cash and resources there
are fun wrinkle - war zones take on
battle royale but it's in - you don't
allow them to become a distraction you
don't want to find yourself trying to
complete one and suddenly notice you're
choking on poison gas because the ring
is closed in on you that said there are
undeniable benefits to picking up
contracts that should not be ignored
scavenger contracts will reward you for
opening a series of supply boxes but
even if you don't have the opportunity
to collect all three of them picking off
the contract will still direct you to a
cache containing money and loot so if
you're light on cash or gear a scavenger
contract will guide you right to where
you need to go similarly a bounty
contract will alert you to the general
location of a fall you need to hunt down
find that poor soul and take them out
successfully and you'll be handsomely
rewarded but even if you have no
intention of completing the contract say
because you're low on armor or ammo
still having the
general location of an enemy or
potentially an enemy squad is good Intel
because it lets you avoid combat to
enjoy your stay in the gulag modern
warfare is most significant addition to
the Battle Royale framework is the gulag
a prison you're dragged to after being
taken out on the main island
your first instinct upon getting rolled
by another team might be to quit the
game but if you stick with it you may
just get another shot at rejoining your
squad in the same match after a few
moments in prison you'll get matched up
with another player for a one-on-one
gunfight match where you're given a
random loader of weapons and thrown into
a fight in the prison showers other
players in the rafters can watch on and
they can even Pelt you with rocks the
winner of the fight will get to enjoy a
nice hot shower and will be redeployed
back on to the current match actually
the shower bit isn't true but you will
get put back on the island
stinky essentially the gulag gives you
an automatic second chance at redemption
provided you've got the skills and
cunning to survive the presence trials
as mentioned previously if your
teammates earn enough cash in game
either by completing bounties or by
scavenging through buildings they can
purchase a second chance at life for you
at a buy station your redeployment will
take place near where your teams spend
their money which means they'll have to
wait for you to land and you'll arrive
in a weakened state still you're back
with your buddies and that's what
matters go for the loadouts if you're
not reviving your squad and have some
cash to spare you want to try and
purchase a loadout pack whenever you can
buying a loadout drop allows you to call
down your personal customized loadout
from the rest of the modern warfare
standard more player modes if you've put
in the time and unlock guns with
attachments it means you can bring in
the kit you're used to and confident
with into warzone effectively removing
the need to run around scooping up loot
and making yourself vulnerable to
enemies hiding behind trees or doors
like absolute cowards
the real benefit of getting your custom
loadout in war zone is the perks war
zone players don't start with
multiplayer perks in a match but if you
can get your lowdown to the game you'll
also get its perks that means along with
your preferred guns you could end up by
increasing your revive speed or making
you sprint faster if you've got that
setup days
not every perk is handy so it pays to
build a warzone specific loadout and
have it ready to go and pick up your
speed or making killstreaks cheaper to
purchase in warzone can give you a big
advantage in battle so it's worth
considering those when a loadout drops
onto a map it's visible to everyone
which means you could go after another
player's package and usually the risk is
worth the reward especially if you've
gotten a poor gear set from just picking
up what's around keep track of those
redeployment layers between the Gulag
and purchasing redeployments a lot of
players can rejoin warzone matches even
though they've been eliminated but to
make sure your teammates second and
third chance is on in vain you'll need
to keep an eye out for their signal
flares which shoot way up into the sky
and glow brightly flares often launch
from the by stations where a squad can
bring their teammate into the game a
player is dropping back into the game
with next to nothing on that spot and a
short-handed squad is probably waiting
nearby for their teammate to return as
you can guess these signal flares will
be visible to all players so it's up to
you to figure out the best time to use
them as aggressive players can use
flares as a guide to help get them drop
on weak teammates and knock them out of
the game on the other hand if you want
to be cautious flares are a good
indication of where not to go
since you know players will be waiting
nearby and the flare could draw other
teams looking for an opportunistic
attack either way flares can give you a
lot of information so keep an eye out
for them be smart with your cache while
out in the field and taking on different
contracts you'll be able to collect cash
for your soldier this currency can
purchase new equipment from the many
shops scattered around the map these
shops include rare and epic level
support items and weapons which can come
in clutch during a fight well they're
all said you're much better off saving
up your currency for when you feel
you'll need it the most
along with purchasing items
can be invested in redeploying down
squadmates what's interesting about the
redeploy option is that it can still
revive players who have fallen in battle
after escaping the gulag giving them yet
another chance are fighting in the
current bow since every member of the
squad has their own pool of cash you
want to make sure that you have enough
money in your reserves in case a squad
mate suffers an untimely fate be a team
player and share the wealth making sure
you're as well equipped as you can be is
a key part of any battle royale game but
since war zone is about squads of three
you also want your team mates to be in
the best shape they can be each player
in warzone gathers cash separately so
when you're thinking about potentially
hitting a buy station it's usually best
to pull your squads resources together
collecting money can be somewhat slower
for a single person but a whole team can
combine their funds pretty quickly and
between two or three of you you'll often
find that you can afford things like
load outs or squad redeployments without
too much effort this also extends to
gear and other items on the field one
big thing to keep an eye on is armor
which can be the deciding factor in a
gunfight you can equip three pieces of
armor on yourself at any given time or
you can carry up to five pieces having a
couple of spare pieces of armor can help
you if you get into trouble but if your
teammates are low the better plan might
be to share them you can quickly pull up
your inventory with down on the d-pad
then highlight an item and drop it for a
teammate that includes armor pieces
which can help bring your squad up to
full strength quickly there you have it
a few tips to help you survive the
brutal warzone keep them in mind when
dropping onto the island and they might
help you get that coveted win if you've
got a few tips of your own share them in
the comments below and for more coverage
of call of duty modern warfare Wars on
mode keep an eye on GameSpot
[Music]
you